the tournament there was an issue at the
lack okay here we go here we go here we
go here we go some technical
difficulties with the stream just before
this tournament second time that this
has happened okay
anyhow hopefully things defect I wonder
if it was actually something do it my
sound that seems way off anyhow 30
minutes 30 minute
this is the cute fanatics quick kill
maybe okay that's a fork Bishop takes
was kind of appealing I'm on the Queen
and the rook
um let's hit the Queen again maybe
there's a way I could get the Queen okay
and get that now just save my knight
save my knight and then do what okay I
want to get castle oh they opping that
night jeez my opponent could have taken
that back okay I got to move my knight
here could have taken that night he
wasn't pinned
he wasn't pinned Wow okay I want to move
this pawn what a bug take that Wits
check looking for a fork if the bishop
goes too far away this is dropping the
farm the farm back to tournament whoa
five four two two okay double those
points E 4 E 4 and then what hmm
my opponents not moving is gonna be the
double the point now they are moving ah
they tricked me they tricked me did this
guy do that last time remember somebody
doing that was it this guy is that his
tactic
maybe there's this night going meeting
one threat pawn push that's not this is
me at one - King gonna move yes back to
tournament six I have a one-point lead
but it's very early on we call us and it
was all about it I still think it's a
good idea to go with they're not gonna
be taken let's push them around pressure
on that night support them I think I
almost played to f6 by mistake okay stay
on that diagonal throw a question of
this Bishop okay it's time to come over
here now that Bishop is devoted to the
Queen side light square weaknesses I'm
really tempted to take the knight and
jump my knight into here
let's do this Queen out next I'm not
even gonna take that rep I like this
square
okay I was think about taking the night
again this is gonna be dangerous isn't
it
Queen takes pawn where is the main this
just seems too right to not do
although pond takes bishop what am I
missing
my knight was unprotected as well Queens
in a pin my Knights can I go here it's
got to be something I could be doing
move my knight they only have 17 seconds
and we have 17 seconds Bishop check
moves Knight check moves it's tough to
calculate all this and my opponent has
no time actually so I'm gonna do this no
matter what and then this no matter what
the down on time back to tournament 12 9
6 ok um ok yes yes yes let's go I
thought I got to those doubling the
points first fantasy variation all right
just develop yeah let's just watch over
there reinforce this Queen d2 I'll play
e5 as soon as the knight develops aren't
I winning a pawn here on that Queen and
I could follow up with f4 my knight has
to be a bit scary
now I'm getting out that Square now
everything is falling everything is
falling now my resign they resigned back
to tournament 20:29
6 6 a bunch of sixes okay Casper
25 minutes 20 seconds Oh oh no time 15
second rule 15 second rule double the
points and then you get the W that's 15
seconds why isn't it working are you
kidding
what's going on here ah ah man a time
ticker man okay well hopefully it's not
an issue on my end
okay
come on I thought I should have just
gotten the W what's with the I had the
stakes doubled okay apparently the 15
second roll is inconsistent thirty
thirty 1712 all right where we at
it's not even pairing me up quickly am i
whining too much by whining too much
okay
French we know more what is going on in
this tournament
non movers everywhere okay here we go we
have action I don't know what to believe
like at first I think it's my internet
and then I just I just don't know what
to think that's the extent of it okay
pawn takes I take with my queen night
out I could pin it open up the e-file
I'm two moves away from getting my rook
on the e1 maybe I'll consider taking
with my knight now putting pressure on
this let me just take them and then I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna Castle no matter
what but let's first see okay Knight
takes I'll take upon takes I take with
my knight pawn push I jump into c6 and
then take on d5 then get on the e-file
thirty-seconds tune up a ton of time
this might happen c5 or e5 jump in take
on d5 get to c6 with tempo if anything
will be c5 because I'm threatening it
okay right here and I'm feeling like I
could do anything at this point because
of just the time situation anything I
might just be doing in anything move
less than 10 seconds 14 black down on
time nothing I don't know I have to
check the server now is that what's
gonna happen oh man I'm getting hit with
everything okay back to turn 40 to 20 20
20 a slight cushion ever so slight
cushion okay have I played this guy
before let's see
let's see castle b5 Bishop b7 they're
not going in that direction stop that
stop that move right now which direction
are you gonna go still go Knight g4 okay
let me do this and I can stop the
bishops pressure against that point kick
them away and then just jump back here
but not just yet more development now
about here and then I'll take with my
pawn actually the rook opposite the
Queen get my dark square Bishop doing
something the night might jump in here I
should have considered Knight here take
with my rook and then my queen I have a
really good dark square control after
watch out for f7 f6 is sufficient Bishop
c5 actually then just drop back Bishop
here main threat maybe I should have
tried to check first I probably would
have been better pawn push open up this
side of the board where the King is
running to now 21 seconds each okay I
could grab that pun let me do that I'm
on c3 if the knight moves dark-squared
control let me just drop back I should
probably just Castle its Castle and then
Bishop here that's a nasty pin it's
caught in a crossfire Bishop c3 next
Bishop takes pawn next just double
actually no matter what do this time
anything back to tournament 56 56 30 30
28 28 a lot of 28 less than 20 minutes
remaining
okay let's go with some type of a grand
prix here i wanted to go to squares
let's get on this diagonal my opponent
tries to fiend cut out there there
LightScribe bishop there could there
could be an issue how are they gonna
Castle now how are they gonna Castle
Knight here that could be a pain
actually Knight check it's probably
going to be deadly and it is deadly
don't take the bishop I just give made
on f7 back to tournament 72 42 42 less
than 19 okay
um still go with this it works it works
in bullet at least d6 Queen c7 is being
snuffed out however I had a fork
actually it wouldn't have worked could
have been a check first or a capture my
Nike get kicked away let's get rid of
the LightSquared bishop it's probably
the most dangerous guy around get rid of
him and then I have a to do--and zero
majority in the center and now I'm
winning upon I'm gonna hang on to him
let me eliminate this Knight really
gonna take that just take him out and
now jump my knight in to d5 play here
get rid of that bishops position King
position grab this pawn but not just yet
I almost defended with rook c7 now I
could grab here bring my light back and
now push my pawn away just keep running
back rank issues as well
um okay right here and then I can make
sure that pond I hang on to him night be
for to hear is gonna be brutal hitting
everything twenty seconds each twenty
seconds each here no matter what I'm on
the bishop push the pond no matter what
back to term at they resigned ninety 56
42 42
oh man I'm a bit tired actually I'm not
used to doing a lot going from
assignment jumping right into this okay
let's open this up just a little bit
okay right here's fine Bishop here trade
bishop's castle Queen their Castle
kingside not not Queen side because my
beep on watch out for what some Forks
might have been there and do some
weakness let's reinforce this pun this
guy going actually okay let me do this
I'm gonna get kicked around Oh night
here is brutal isn't it I don't know
that there's a great follow up just yet
okay I'm winning upon with that um it's
this Queen for a second here queen Shaq
ah
okay well I'm up a pawn in this in this
position that night just kind of dead I
don't want to take them there
LightScribe bishop here's what I want to
get rid of okay let's not allow them to
double up my knight in a better spot
that Bishop I should just taken this pun
I could grab this one and now the night
is going to be landing on that furthest
support point let's just watch over my
base point I only have 30 Twila have 12
seconds need a fork okay I could get
that night I'm getting the rook okay
eight point six I should be able to get
this this is plenty of time plenty of
time
get my king up my opponent is flying
though he is definitely flying no right
here okay they resigned back to
tournament Wow where did my time go I
don't know how much time I started off
with but or where I was thinking in that
game wow it just seemed like I was down
to less than 20 seconds before any
before I knew it
okay knight c6 my Knights out okay I
have an issue with my pawn structure but
it's not gonna be okay maybe I should
have just considered taking that night
okay I think Knight here was better okay
now this is gonna be a bit of an
inconvenience let's see how they deal
with pressure on that night
no I'm just gonna I'm gonna do this I
could have taken that night should I
have no I will okay I didn't want to
work out the calculations I think it I
think it would be all right let me see
pawn push pawn push this is gonna get
ripped open very soon
this is officially getting ripped open
Queen is caught in the crossfire and the
whole farm is going right now
rook check mean take spawned Queen here
check it's gonna be me actually that was
me my bishop was controlling that corner
square I missed that oh man okay
13 13 minutes for meeting 1:30 88 caps
fan okay everybody's playing that East
six move everybody's playing that East
six bills I'm not gonna recapture with
my queen I wouldn't have captured my
Queen now I have a strong a five-point
now I want to get my pawn going to f4 f5
excuse me this is difficult to deal with
right here Queen takes pawn pawn push oh
my bishop here I could care less about
that Jeep on I want to go towards their
king now this is a brutal passed pawn
this Bishop is shot out of the game how
do I make progress or I do pawn push
Queen can't see okay this is a whole
jump into it oh okay I have that
defendant I could play Bishop h5 and
then Knight here I'm jumping into all
these good squares now deadly fork
what's happening capture and it's a fork
the queen is dead
follow up with the rook give a check
over here
double rooks grab this on anything at
this point
push this guy
get the Queen involved and then get that
rook out of there I'm also on the bishop
the bishop moves it to me it's not
moving watch out for stalemate no
stalemate they resigned back to
tournament 150 111 105 okay 12 minutes
remaining
watch out for that deadly f7 square oh
man to be ever so delicate ever so
delicate okay I'm gonna get pushed
around I'm getting pushed around I
should just take that bishop right away
I was trying to get fancy just trying to
get fancy on that one
Bishop b7 pawn push I jump into center
square would they really give up their
LightSquared Bishop it's a possibility
for sure I'm not gonna take that that's
a sneaky trick Bishop f4 and I'm gonna
be trapped so I'm not really winning
upon there okay um get rid of that light
square Bishop now I want to get rid of
him when I could have gotten rid of him
earlier in one shot now let's do this
target that pawn maybe can I get to that
pun that's it free Queen miss that one I
mean one threat not easy to defend the
rook f2 doesn't even do it this is gonna
be game this is like a matin for or
something there's some checks pawn
pushes rook f2 back to tournament their
design 170 132 125 10 minutes remaining
teen night teen night open Sicilian
we've been here before in 5-minute games
okay
what's this night up to what's he up to
okay okay I'm area with this I was
drawing clean position
I have a strong queen position still in
a function on the dark squares get over
here my king wants to be on a fast track
towards the center could he get to c5
he's officially at c5 he's a walking
King he's actually he's very fast a
walking King what does that even mean
I have all the base points secure and
the play is now going to ensue on this
side and that pond is going to fall that
pond is gonna drop but there's no rush
how can i improve my position let's try
this
actually that's not improving liking no
this is a better King position I could
grab this pawn you know let's just grab
that pond actually I was trying to get
this pawn up to c5 let's come over here
it's gonna be safe over here let's try
it over here again this is where my king
wants to be over here let's get this
pawn this one and then this one and then
get pushing cut the King off first
pigs swing over where swing over here
let's throw on some checks easy to go
wrong here all right
where is the main are there any mates
actually there isn't any means let's
come back that was bad technique okay
this should still be alright
should still be all right we're gonna
see about that that's actually me back
to tournament 19151 145 8 minutes
remaining now to play against John
Madden when you see this guy be drawn
circles and squares everywhere X's and
O's so the X's and O's Man Queen b6 I'm
hitting f7 in that Bishop they're gonna
take that pawn it's not good it's not
good if they do that okay I really want
to hang on to my bishop it's gonna get
kicked away isn't it ya could have taken
it then Knight there there's a knight
check it's a little scary it's a lot
scary actually
don't let the cling it to h6 I need some
breathing room I need some breathing
room Bishop here is gonna give me some
breathing room or is it I wanna get the
light script bishops off can I make that
happen
pawn push again jump into here and as
soon as it's taken I open up the
diagonal for my light square bishop okay
let's play here I'm on this Queen trade
get that night out of there okay pawn up
pawn up here is where I want to be even
if I have to give up my bishop I don't
want to give up this pawn that's too
much I have zero compensation now at
least I have some compensation get rid
of this Knight okay oh they couldn't
take that they could take that pawn now
let's come back got that rook pawn push
and then get my up let's just do this
it's pond rolling there's this nightgown
well I feel like I was close to being in
a fork am i doing
not much time
time time burners where you at oh my
goodness John Madden oh man I only I won
on time man
weren't you supposed to be commentating
a game or something right now I heard
about that come on man it's Thanksgiving
at least here it's Thanksgiving here I
thought he was supposed to be
commentating is he multitasking is that
what's going on
okay let's take like this open up the D
file wow you knocked the wind out of me
John Madden oh I could have taken the
Queen take free Queens
oh my goodness they're so free that was
the freest queen around c7 take that
Queen oh man
okay land a check the very least just
land it Jack drop-back killed a knight
okay they resigned back to tournament
where they've getting mated or something
I don't know to 3191 how much time is
left there's only five minutes five
minutes
five-minute warning 5:30 it's a free
pond she's trade and I could I could
actually hang on to that guy
okay are they gonna take this is gonna
turn out to be a tsunami of ponds in the
center a tsunami of ponds coming up
Bishop d7 to b5 oh man
that actually works that actually works
thankfully that one works okay if I
played Bishop here the knight would have
blocked and gave check okay
now I could just defend Queen here is
that gonna be brutal I could block with
my bishop
okay now everything's okay my king does
not want to castle
get that rope out of the control of f5
so now that there's no there's no pond
push I could jump in here and then
secure my bishop if my bishop is not
interrupted then can't do anything and
he's not going anywhere he's going
nowhere
kitchen sink back to tournament 250 250
191 141 now I seem to always end up
playing this guy towards the end of a
tournament and I seem to always go into
the main line when I'm playing the white
side we've been here before
okay I'm gonna take that pawn gain some
tempo on the Queen okay my rook here
jumped my knight in can't take then that
all I could but the knight would have to
go back to d7 alright let's try to open
this up oh man that was a mistake that
was what you call a mistake um this guy
is close to put me to sleep he's close
to putting me to sleep more bad jokes on
the way oh man I got to do that huh
that's not even saving me what am i
doing oh my goodness I'm dropping
everything oh no I have no hope at time
burners I got to resign this no I hid a
job oh I lost the farm to 48 why did I
lose that oh I did f5 I should've done
f5 I was getting too careless least I
have a cushion at least I have a cushion
ah man why did I do that
there was no recovery usually I would be
like yeah let's do time burners I didn't
even have time burners you need to have
pieces in order to do time burners
remember that remember that time burners
101 that's where you learn that in order
to do time burners you need to have time
learners around you need to have pieces
okay let's focus here throw a pod down
here throw a pond down here that game
ended so fast ff5 man is that Mike dead
he is isn't he
he is isn't he could do bishop here that
Queen is close to dead isn't she
pick up that night let's pick that
Knight up
what is that even doing so he called
Mouse lip Mouse lip now the Queen is
close to cooked now she's close to
cooked and she is cooked my rook is
falling trade one minute 46 I'm just
gonna kill that tricky night get rid of
that tricky tricky night okay anything
right here is me back to Terminal one
2602 68 oh there's a 268 261 oh I got a
play against the major major pond oh if
I could come back to bite me for sure my
lead evaporated evaporated you can grab
that pond ah oh that's a free bishop am
i doing helping my opponent develop for
one at that night of the rook
Bishop here get on this diagonal I'm the
queen are they gonna resign I'm not
resigning huh that was close to main I'm
gonna close to me are they just gonna do
time burners that's me
I needed that one back to tournament 81
30 seconds remaining they're gonna call
it they call it just a nick it's like
the buzzer beater there was 30 seconds
it was showing oh man a buzzer beater I
was not expecting that
oh it's been a while a buzzer beater oh
my goodness nap three why'd you have to
make things so crazy towards the end if
it wasn't for you there wouldn't been no
buzzer beater oh yeah good games out